that face you make when you see a
big-ass booty what is going on you two
y'all hear about that e-boat oh my god
you followed us here
Ebola Ebola is here in the United States
and I'll tell you right now and we are
[ __ ]
Oh everybody's gonna get Ebola Angola I
saw that [ __ ] on Twitter with that girl
that Ebola was an African Prince
I believe it my name is busy boy I would
give y'all some strength advice on how
to survive Ebola flu virus and vote a
clue
number one and Ebola is in the air
yeah [ __ ] what you need to do is walk
around with a cup of breakfast because
if somebody breeze you and you get any
bonus number two is in the United States
and then about 72 people that caught it
and they gonna spit it to 4,000 other
people including your babies hide your
kids hide your wife but Ebola go find
you oh you [ __ ] I'm trying to go
outside seho have an alkyl filter to
tighten up your finger but the whole
cover your mouth cause you don't want
any offices to go out and spread Ebola
this is you this is Ebola Ebola that for
rocket launches two knives 17 dicks and
you got eight buttholes to be [ __ ] in
and that's what a bola is we can't fight
it it's done this [ __ ] ain't jay-z
saying he go over tired of [ __ ] and
still coming back [ __ ] how many
times has jay-z retire [ __ ] you
ain't gonna quit we should call you
Ebola [ __ ] oh I'm gonna tell y'all
something right now at the super top
secret Ebola turns you into a zombie
Ebola is actually a word for monkey
disease follow your [ __ ] that
don't know hold up this just in people
to come for bets on your people [ __ ]
us up bets are birds that Jesus forgot
to love right you don't pray and because
you don't pray the flu evolved into
Ebola just wait that [ __ ] turn Chinese
it's gonna be called Ebola life's over
the stream I gave my money to charity
tell my mom and dad I love them and I
jacked off about 14 times my penis is
wrong ah
where's Madagascar huh I heard he bola
went into of the African islands of
Madagascar Madagascar in Africa
how you gonna go to Africa nobody bullet
and then come back the United States you
a terrorist shaking hands breathing in
that air and then go exhaling on all of
us
I got we got babies here you are you a
baby too
I don't even know why white people want
to go to Africa that's focused there are
African people that don't want to go
back you want to go vacation to ask a
bro but those of you who have not picked
it up this is [ __ ] sad time calm the
[ __ ] down